hello there we've been playing fortnite
now for over four years and over that
time you've probably met some of the
people who fit into these categories
because today we are looking at 21 types
of fortnite player be honest in the
comments and tell us which categories
you fall into if i missed something
please let me know and we'll make a part
two oh and please do the like and
subscribe thing i'm trying to get to two
million subscribers
the first player type is the og they've
been playing fortnite since season zero
and have the skins to back it up a
purple skull trooper a pink ghoul
trooper or even the og renegade raider
these guys have supported the game since
day zero and are proud of that they also
most likely have a fully decked out a
mega skin from og season 4. the next
player we all know especially since the
chapter 2 days is the glitch abuser
these guys are all about the xp to level
up yet they don't want to actually play
the game and work for it instead they'd
rather find a glitch and stand in one
place for 10 hours watching their level
swell these guys have nothing to be
proud of but they'll constantly flaunt
their level above you a little different
to this is the grinder from the first
second of the season they look at the
challenges and get every single one of
them done within the first few days
they've hit level 100 and then suddenly
level 200 without buying any tears at
all they know everything about
challenges they know the best missions
they know which ones are most profitable
and which should be avoided they get
their enjoyment from grinding it out or
legitimately of course
the best grinders will also own a fully
golden peely from chapter two season two
next we have another form of
completionist but this person is all
about cosmetics the collector collectors
want to own everything ever created in
fortnite and will be ready with the v
bucks to pursue this dream it starts off
with collecting a few marvel skins then
that becomes a desire to collect every
single john snapshot and suddenly they
want it all every single cosmetic there
is some can be loud and obnoxious but
usually collectors are humble and only
show off their lockers when asked on
average they've spent over four thousand
dollars to achieve this feat the best
ones use code adamaru okay that last bit
was a lie but it's worth the shot the
antithesis of the collector is the
beggar and sadly we all know at least
one of them to them v-bucks aren't
needed as they'd rather stalk their
friends and beg for gifts constantly
they are the worst kind of people who
usually find themselves without a party
invite because they keep on begging for
items they're the type of people who
wait for a free item to hit the shop and
then gift you that free item they're the
worst type of people around so my advice
to you is to cut them off get the
beggars out of your life
[Music]
next we have the mima over the years
these guys have realized winning is an
empty feeling and having fun is way more
important they'll build hearts in the
final circle and let solo bots win games
winning means so little to them now that
they'll sky base and try to hit a one
pump from max height knowing if they
fail the game is over i mean who hasn't
wanted to play an entire game web
slinging around a chicken these guys are
destined to be the next successful
content creators playing a game purely
for fun onto the troll these players are
like memers but they prefer to do things
to hurt other players and kill their
enjoyment usually the mystique skin is
in their locker for its shape-shifting
abilities they find an npc target and
take their place it doesn't matter if
it's a quest giving bots or the
foundation himself they want to deceive
everyone in the lobby and take advantage
of them the moment you think you're safe
is the moment they pounce a knife in the
back is imminent and even when they're
on your side too they'll find a way to
take you down usually they'll cut down
the builds under your feet the next
player type is the pro they are addicted
to the highest levels of competition and
love to scrim and play arena standard
public games are beneath them and only
the rush of arena can fill their boots
these players can tarp like pros and
tunnel like a mole they mean business no
time for fun at all competition is
everything they can make an average skin
become a try-hard sweat skin in no time
at all speaking of tryhards that's the
next category these chaps aren't to the
same level of the pros usually they
haven't made a penny from playing games
yet they act like they are the next
booger they usually wear skins that look
sweaty and spend hours in creative
trying to up their game every season
they become disheartened and quit
fortnite and yet return three days later
with the exact same goals they want to
be a pro player and they are going to
get there no matter what you can easily
identify a tryhard they over build
constantly they build way too much and
fall damage is their real enemy
then we have the pub stomper these
players are great at the game dropping
10 to 15 kills per game and dominating
completely a pub stomper knows they are
not good enough to play at the pro level
and instead feel superior by dominating
casual lobbies the problem is each
elimination only covers the cracks that
they will never be good enough to go pro
their only option is to become a content
creator expect 20 plus games on their
youtube channel every single week then
we have the fanboy these types of
players like to cosplay as their
favorite youtubers and twitch streamers
they have meticulously studied the
locker of the top streamers and know
which back bling rap and pickax they use
they want to pay homage to content
creators and enjoy the attention they
receive for perfect recreations and even
a budget youtuber like me it feels weird
when you bump into the exact same
character model as yourself but cool the
fanboy usually evolves into the
fashionista they know so much about
creating locker presets and perfectly
matching colours and styles they know
when a certain color of red doesn't
match and will only showcase a new skin
combo once it's absolutely perfect if
they've been doing this for years you'll
find a skin from chapter 1 a back bling
from chapter 2 and the glider from
chapter 3 all perfectly combined to
create visual perfection the fashionista
is the locker and skin combo expert
another type of skin enthusiast exists
the elitist the elitist prides
themselves on wearing the most rare and
hard to obtain skins they'll be rocking
the double helix or royal bomber to
simply flex as hard as they can skins
which are only available with real world
purchases like a console or graphics
card the elitist is here to show their
dominance financially whether it's
theirs or their mum and dads no one will
know from the original galaxy skin to
the icon and more recently the dark
scully money is no object for the
elitist i think it's time we give a
mention to the furries these are the
people who quite like humans and animals
being morphed into one in fortnite they
tend to be addicted to cuddle team
leader and her counterparts feathers
hair bright colours it all floats their
boats and they will wear it with pride
they own that weird six-foot fox they
can be seen wearing snugs daily and
moussels is a god to them if the skin
isn't human they're going to buy it but
come on let's be honest i guess we're
all a little bit partial to meowtals
[Music]
the next player is the daily dropper
these guys are simple and straight to
the point each day they log in for one
reason to do their daily quests and 20
minutes later they've switched off again
they've bought the battle pass on day
one and intend to get to tier 100 but if
they don't enjoy the game right now
they'll only jump in for one match
before moving to another game they love
fortnite but have enough self-control to
play other games the thing is with the
daily dropper they'll always be back
tomorrow slowly gaining battle pass
tears i bet one of your friends is a
lore expert this player is totally
involved in the story of fortnite they
know all the actors of each role and can
name everyone who has impacted the
narrative of fortnite the most devoted
always wear the paradigm skin unless
they've missed it in the store and
instead they rotate through the other
members of the seven io and midas crew
the law expert watches each week for map
updates and finds theories to back up
every possibility they want to know what
will happen next in the story
do you know a fortnight rage quitter if
you don't it's probably you with skill
based matchmaking here to stay rage
quitters are growing in numbers a rage
quitter looks forward to playing
fortnite all day and loves the first few
games in the session but as the lobbies
get harder the rage quitter begins to
crumble they've gone from winning easily
to being punished constantly it's too
much to take and the losses hurt too
much so they leave sometimes it's a
public winch i'm not playing anymore bro
i'm off this game and sometimes they
just vanish leave chat and close out of
fortnite rage has broken them again but
don't worry they'll be back again very
soon then we have the ping hater these
types of players usually have the worst
internet in the world they can barely
stay on a discord call for 10 minutes
without being disconnected of course
they play with friends at the other side
of the world and this leads to bad ping
playing with bad ping can break
everything annoying rubber banding can
throw your character around and build
just sometimes one place at all the
thing is they now have an excuse ready
every single time if they do anything
wrong it's because of ping if they miss
a shot it's because of pink if they
don't box up quick enough it's because
of ping it's never their fault they may
hate their ping but secretly they love
it the next player type is the looter
the looter is the kind of toxic we all
hate their sole purpose each game is to
take your loot at every opportunity you
open a chest and there they are sucking
up everything as they run past some do
this to troll and others honestly have
no idea they are being toxic when you
get a kill they will march straight in
there and take everything they see they
have no time to understand how you feel
no time for protocol and they don't care
about respect it's all about being
selfish and taking what they want
only one thing is worse than that the
abandoner picture this you're dropping
from the battle bus ready to slay the
lobby but what's that on the mini-map
one player has decided to do their own
thing in public lobbies this guy usually
has no mic and doesn't care about their
team at all they are playing solo squads
and only clicked phil for extra
protection but if you're playing with
friends and one suddenly goes a
different direction it's probably
because they have a challenge to
complete and don't want to hustle you
with the details they usually die a
million miles away and ask to be
rebooted now it's your job to travel
four thousand meters in three minutes to
save their sorry asses and finally
number 21 we have the creative warrior
there are two types of these guys the
ones who crank 90s all days in the
pursuit of going pro and then there's
these guys who have completely rejected
battle royale and instead want to create
their own masterpieces every game mode
under the sun is at their fingertips
they can make stunning creative hubs
trending maps worldwide and constantly
come up with new ways to play fortnite
these guys will be impacting fortnite
for years to come and for that you have
my thanks so there we have it 21
different types of fortnite player
you've probably come across and come on
let's be honest do you see yourself in
any of them i have to admit i see myself
in quite a few of these
and it hurts anyway be sure to ruin your
relationships by telling each other what
you think below i'm adam you're awesome
it's been a pleasure i'll see you next
time
[Music]
you